foreign
[Music]
a new super Princess Peach game
Super Mario RPG what
oh my gosh
yes
dude
oh my goodness it looks so good
so I wonder if it's like an exact remake
of the Super Nintendo one
[Music]
I actually never played
the original I played the GameCube one
which was Thousand Year Door
[Music]
but this looks really really fun
again I could see my my kids really
enjoying this too especially my oldest
because he's he he played Pokemon let's
go so he's kind of got an introduction
to RPGs
this might be another good one for him
to try
[Music]
oh man I just love the colors how
everything looks
um
the characters look like a little bit a
little bit smaller than normal
pre-orders begin today on the Nintendo
eShop wow at least on Super NES okay
Mario RPG turns with brand new graphics
whether you played the original game or
not why not take the opportunity to jump
why not
Mario series turn this up a little bit
Mr koizumi that last trailer featured
Mario but he's not the only one getting
a game huh what do you mean what let's
take a peek what
he's not the only one
let's talk about Peach Bowser or Luigi
I was right
[Music]
dude
Princess Peach star is the main
character in a brand new game what a
mystery on this particular spot on stage
they set it up at first to make you
think
this is gonna be about her
what on Earth is happening
that's all we'll show for now we'll
share more details at a later date what
Mr koizumi
there's actually something else what
you're not gonna show anymore
new Luigi's Mansion what visually
enhanced version of Luigi's Mansion Dark
Moon originally released on Nintendo 3DS
is in development oh my God missing more
of Luigi's ghostly dude the one on the
switch was so good
what about the GameCube version though
games will launch next year what about
the GameCube version
Princess Peach and we need the original
man it's like Mario fans have a lot of
games to look forward to
more details will be shared in the
future oh dude let's see some more
headlines that's exciting